hay algo que le impida a bachelet
mostrar públicamente su apoyo a un
candidato presidencial teniendo en
cuenta su puesto y está bien visto
teniendo en cuenta su rol como ex
presidente
hola muy buenas tardes la verdad es que
yo creo que no las normas de conducta de
la administración de los funcionarios de
la administración internacional señala
claramente que es ya que expresan sus
opiniones personales
de manera contacto y discreción lo
pueden hacer y es lo que creo que ya
hizo en este vídeo en el cual anuncia
que vota por gabriel boric no nos llama
a votar en contra de alguien ella
anuncia por quién llama a votar y
decidir e incluso expresamente
respetando las diferencias con los demás
molina que tanto podría influir estas
declaraciones en los comicios
la verdad es que está bastante estrecha
lo quien señalan las encuestas hay una
gran incertidumbre quien vaya a ganar
podría influir evidentemente porque la
expresidenta tiene todavía un capital
político no despreciable y que el
señalar por quién va a votar no llamando
a votar por alguien porque eso no lo
hace llama votar pero no nos llama a
votar por por boris y creo que podría
influir en algunas personas que tienen
todavía dudas respecto a por quién votar
o si es que van a ir a votar ya que en
chile en el sufragio es voluntario